Mr Beast has taken over me and
subscribers but I have one secret trick
up my sleeve book review
listen it was either that or Happy
Wheels part 200.
I should have done Happy Wheels part
200.
here's what I'm gonna do six books that
changed the way I think to show that I
don't care
I no longer care about Subs the first
book I know you have never ever heard of
this thing Buddhism what is that
thanks Ryan the anthology of the Pali
Canaan if you want to read Buddhism go
ahead here you go read it knock yourself
out I see you in a couple years but
thanks to the Buddha's words a summary
you can get to all of the good bits and
Skip all of the repetition there's a lot
of repetition in the pelican
and what have I declared this is
suffering I have declared this is the
origin of suffering I have declared this
is the cessation of suffering I have
declared this is the way leading to the
sensation of suffering I have declared
why have I declared that okay fine this
one also has a lot of repetition
but it obviously has a lot of
interesting things and I'll summarize
the bits that stood out to me we're all
gonna land okay follow along yeah and
we're all gonna die what the [ __ ] do you
do in between only acceptable answer
watch PewDiePie all day okay you're good
Buddhism looks at life as suffering now
I don't personally subscribe to this
idea but they go into depth of talking
about craving and suffering and this
sort of opened my eyes up to
self-control according to Buddhism
craving is suffering if you want
something you are suffering as a
consequence and I know what you're
thinking you little smart ass well if
craving is suffering all I have to do is
get the thing homeless people just buy a
house
look at this dude giving in to every
craving that he has suffering don't work
like that bro sure it might satisfy you
in the moment but after that you're
gonna want another
and then another or a big or a better
at eBay
where does it end well never if we will
go on forever you will keep wanting
stuff and crave forever and be reborn in
the will of samsara
think listen I didn't make that up the
book cited if you think about your
existence as a mere probability and you
already existing being a testimony to
that being a possibility and if time is
infinite or even just space is infinite
then what's not there to say that
to me this is really about self-control
control of your body and don't live as a
passive passenger so to reduce the
suffering of craving is not to limit it
and it's not to give in to it or cheat
days but it's to be free from it by
uprooting it oh this really helped with
my own problems in the past I've talked
about it and I'm free from it
hooray but I think in general
self-control is something it helps you
examine yourself and what you want and
why you want it and is this really going
to help you with anything live life good
don't live forever bad
Buddhism
next book arid Doddle let me say that
normally Nikka McCain ethics
wow what a fun title Please tell me more
Felix okay I will
Aristotle the greatest one no no no
they're one of the greatest philosopher
of all time he studied under plate
though he taught Alexander the Great
himself he said all these amazing things
[ __ ] thought women had less
teeth than men
you could have just checked bro you had
a wife I Googled it
bro what happened
I want to know Nick McCain ethics is the
first philosopher book that I read that
discusses the idea of happiness and 2
300 years or whatever later it
is goddamn relevant so some of us may
look at happiness as reaching wealth
Fame pleasure wrong I tell you why it's
wrong because these things can be
stripped away from you in the moment
[Music]
not happy anymore that is not happiness
happiness is what the Greeks use the
word for yudamonia I think that was the
most Swedish way to say that yudamonia
it's a a state of being of flourishing
as an individual ah so happiness
nothing no one can take away from me
more of a goal than anything and you
reach it by actively being good making
the right choices and practicing virtue
as a habit to oversimplify all of that
don't go on Twitter and Instagram
those are bad habits okay stop it virtue
is an active choice that you as an
individual have to make and we usually
know about it we just don't like to
think about it this is obviously
oversimplifying but this is a really
good book and if this interests you I
recommend reading it and thinking deeper
it personally helped me maintain and
develop better habits for myself and for
that I am thankful even though you can't
count you said some good stuff next but
everyone always talks about stoicism
Marcus are really he was so cool he was
like an emperor but also philosopher
okay sure absolutely but don't sleep on
Epictetus
wait a minute
sleep on
sleep on Epic days
by epictators
last name
base name on the very first page he
describes stoicism perfectly
it's almost like they came up with it
there are things in life that you can
control and there are things in life
that you can't control don't worry about
things you can't control okay for
example whenever I drive in Japan it's
really difficult because the GPS a lot
of times will tell me left but I can
clearly tell that the road is going
right so in that moment I have to make a
decision based on my intuition should I
go left or right and somehow I always
pick the most goddamn choice and my 20
minute trip is all the sudden one
[ __ ] hour just because of the guys
but that doesn't annoy me anymore
because of stoicism stoicism has lately
become more popular and it can of course
be applied to anything they talk a lot
about anger and why that's not a useful
emotion but I don't think people fully
realize to what extent they took this
idea stoicism was a school of thought
that came up during very trialing times
during under tyranny burned down my
house heck of all my belongings take my
arms take my legs don't take my legs but
you can never take my virtue to me
stoicism is all about Freedom you can be
the richest and most powerful but you
can still ultimately be a slave if other
people are controlling your actions if
you have fear of losing what you have
then you are ultimately being controlled
by it and we all have ideas and opinions
of what is good and bad for example
dying is bad right
wrong you're wrong at least according to
stoicism they compare fear of death for
example as similar to a baby crying
about not what getting what they want
because dying is sort of part of nature
you cry baby good or bad doesn't exist
it's just something that we made up the
only thing that is true is what is
according to Nature and I think one of
the things that stands out the most is
that if you are in a situation of
trialing times that's for a stoic an
opportunity rather to display this
virtue this is you demonia and that way
ultimately flipping painship on its hand
doesn't exist thank you I will no longer
be mad at the GPS machine I promise
my point is that it's difficult okay
more even Marcus complain how difficult
that is
gay science
and know what you want to do
it's okay I give you the pass the first
time I read Nietzsche I read Beyond Good
and Evil I didn't understand a goddamn
[ __ ] thing don't watch my book review
it's embarrassing
and I'm not gonna pretend I'm some Niche
scholar now either but I had a bad time
first reading him because he was
referencing all these different
philosophers and I had no clue who they
even were
after reading more philosophy coming
back to Nietzsche again my reaction was
still bad because I went this guy was
making fun of all my heroes
what the [ __ ]
so Nietzsche for me was a slow cook I
will I will admit but the best way to
understand philosophy is to understand
the person behind it and the more I feel
like I had done that the more I came to
love Nietzsche uh he loves his words
he's very great at them he's very harsh
and very brutal but you understand that
he targets philosophers that he likes or
that he at least admires to some degree
I guess some he just [ __ ] hate it but
you know Star Wars is him is passionless
can't refute it but to me what stands
out the most is his life-affirming work
Niche wanted to overcome nihilism look
at this book look how dark and epic and
scary it is oh nihilism that's what it's
all about no he wanted to overcome it
Mana there's life is suffering boohoo
[ __ ] it's not that life is suffering
it's what we do with that suffering give
meaning to it we all know this already a
hero's tale would be nothing without the
villain it's that simple I feel like I
have a lot to say about monster jamane I
might keep it for another time I can
tell you however before reading
Nietzsche I listened to Kelly Clarkson
Stronger what doesn't kill you and I had
no visible reaction now I listen to it
and I go
thank you Kelly Clarkson I get it now
next but this one is a bit out of left
field the mathematical Universe yeah I
pretty much talked about all of these
books already so I apologize for the
repetition I have declared but this book
brought up so many scientific
possibilities that I had obviously no
[ __ ] clue about they were never
taught to me in school and to me they're
just mind-blowing I really don't want to
sound like that one ninja tweet I can't
stop thinking about Quantum fixes or
whatever it is or to be that one person
that brings up the double slit
experiment in every single goddamn
conversation I have been that person I
apologize
but most of these philosophy books that
I'm previously mentioned uh they were
written so long ago where in a time
where people didn't know much about the
world or our universe for that matter so
the possibilities seemed endless now we
know so much about the world and I would
like to know less of it okay am I the
only one with this opinion the sun is a
giant ball of gas
Hindu thank you so much science now I
don't need an iPhone 12 instead of 11.
it doesn't matter I'm joking what's
really stood out the most to me in this
book was the idea of parallel universes
I made a video about it as well but how
it's actually logically possible I feel
like it it puts me not just in the mind
of all these philosophy books but also
in the time it's crazy to me how ideas
discussed thousands of years ago have a
logical foot in science today and even
philosophy about happiness still has a
relevance I think this book did such a
great job at describing these complex
ideas in a way that's easily digestible
and to me this is very exciting I don't
think we'll ever know everything but I
also think that doesn't matter because
we will always have philosophy
next but I randomly stumbled upon this
book this book launching it's written by
what I think is the greatest philosopher
of our time PewDiePie
I don't know who that is but I would
love to collaborate with him one day
all right that's it oh congrats Mr Beast
obviously just joking but delete your
channel as promised you have 24 hours